[Music]
you're a couple right yes yeah oh you're
jade you're dating no no we're not
dating
wait so what are you guys maybe like one
day it could get to that but like you
know like as of now like you know like
we are friends and like we see each
other and we have sex and it sounds like
you're dating yeah just without the
title i guess that's like when people
that's like that's like when people like
have a badge and a gun and stop people
and give out tickets but they're like
i'm not a cop
yeah uh you have all the functions of a
cop yeah but i don't like titles uh
[ __ ] you're doing the job of a cop what
should we call our relationship how
would you define it lover side piece to
girlfriend-ish
i don't even know what to call this
because you be making it tough sometimes
like i don't even know what i'm doing
wrong like damn i'd be trying to get
flowers sometimes don't work like we
have sex it'd be cool and then next day
now you're a piece of [ __ ] like
i am going through something in my head
which is why it's kind of back and forth
but i'm definitely not messing with
other people so like it is only you but
it's the title part that just needs to
be worked on
all right
can we appreciate that like
with these generations they're the ones
who invent the most labels and then all
of a sudden they're afraid of labels
that like random times like it just it
really doesn't make sense they have
these abstract labels that mean nothing
and they want to like absorb them and be
like yeah uh
i'm not heterosexual or homosexual i'm
like omnisexual i'm like what does that
mean it's like uh you know it's kind of
when you're like glazing in between okay
so you have a label for nothingness
but you got a whole [ __ ]
relationship and you want to sit there
and be like uh we vibing
then why don't you just vibe with your
gender expression too [ __ ] like what is
how do i maybe i'm just confused but
they will say they hate labels but what
do you mean by they they they or they
it's like folks nowadays always say that
they hate labels they hate labels right
but then there's such an abundance of
labels that you keep creating and
adhering to yeah i'm a sapiosexual i'm a
this and that what are you guys you guys
dating we're vibing
what's wrong with the title
well because it comes up with pressure
yeah exactly uh what did you think that
relationship was just like fun flowers
and [ __ ] like yeah those
no they don't want to see relationships
outside of uh you know uh
i'm just out here giving out tickets i'm
vibing i'm not a police officer
uh you know i'm just uh putting out this
fire i'm vibing i'm not a firefighter
uh i'm just inside your [ __ ] as a
gynecologist but i'm actually not
gynecologist i'm just vibing in your
vagina what do another one
twitter would another one
[Laughter]
uh i'm just out here
vibing
i don't like labels because they come
with so much pressure i work in a
hospital but you know i'm not a nurse i
just vibing fighting
and she said you could talk to whoever
you want go be with whoever you want and
i'ma do what i want to do and i said i
said you are you are an adult i can't
tell you what you can and can't do it
would be very upsetting if you were only
sleeping with me i think that would
negate the whole point of it all again
[ __ ] don't want to be labeled
as jealous they want to experience
everything in his own experience i'm not
just i'm just experiencing a vibe but
hey
to be fair i think you could feel anger
and not be an angry person sure the same
way i think you were angry yes i was
angry no i was feeling anger i
understand yeah but
but if it's there it's there yeah
jealousy is not like oh no it's like
no you're uh i'm gonna disagree actually
go ahead yeah i think you can feel
whatever you want until you manifest it
into real action it doesn't really mean
that much if you feel it you feel it it
means something that feeling is there it
doesn't mean anything feelings come and
go it doesn't necessarily mean that
they're meaningful
so let's say you're feeling jealous but
you never act on it how real is that
jealousy
still real something that you feel you
might not act upon it like make
something but if you're going to feel
certain that
what do you mean by act on it let's just
put that in uh manifest it into the
world
so do you think that the thoughts that
you have actually mean something
uh no not necessarily that's that's true
how can i show you i think about punting
kids every now
on you like leave that [ __ ] that's a
[ __ ] up thought yeah you know what i'm
saying
does it mean you're a terrible person
yes anyways
but you get what i'm saying
and i say this because
you're right because
the feelings that overcome you sometimes
you feel helpless to them but i also
tell folks if you're observing it
there's a separation between you and
whatever it is that you're feeling so i
don't think necessarily feeling
something indicates that there's
something wrong with you right because
people beat themselves up i feel angry
sometimes when i don't have my weight
okay well what do you do about that
anger do you put it on your partner no i
just find ways to have little outlets
and like let it kind of
blow over
you're doing the work you're doing the
work you're doing your work that's what
you're saying you know i'm saying a
jealous person who doesn't manifest her
jealousy through controlling behavior or
anything like that is doing fantastic
and and i would say
you can't give credence to every emotion
that you have and say it defines you or
it really means something i have times
where i get super angry you'll never see
me manifest that outwardly and get
scream at people or say a bunch of stuff
why because i'm doing what i can to
control gonna work does that make me an
angry person i don't think so but that
anger is there underneath and you're
controlling it at least i don't know
that's just something i think but maybe
you guys have a different philosophy let
us know in the comments that makes sense
have you slept with someone else since
we've been sleeping with each other yeah
yes nope
how would you feel if i slept with
someone else
a little jealous would you take me back
if i slept with someone else
yes
but i need test results yeah that's fun
just fine i'll give it to you tomorrow
you know there's an interesting thing i
don't want to label it i'm trying to
figure it out in my head but also feel
just so you guys have all the makings of
exclusive relationships in terms of how
you feel about each other and all this
stuff but you don't want the label don't
don't cast it out there hey you don't
want to make it real who knows maybe
this girl's going through some kind of
trauma or something terrible and it's
stopping her from dating i don't really
know but
generally i think this is a very popular
thing now to just be like
oh you know we're just chilling you're
not really labeling it you just [ __ ]
buddy say you [ __ ] buddies make that
clear but don't sit in the in between
act like a couple then get surprised
when someone gets hurt because they
thought you were a couple
you can say whatever you want but if you
treat the person like your significant
other you know what i'm saying you give
them the significant other benefits then
you set confusing boundaries you get
what i'm saying
it's like oh yeah this is my girlfriend
but i'm making you sign a contract to be
my wife yeah uh excuse me
same thing it's like you calling this
person your girlfriend but you're making
them sign a contract with your wife
that makes sense your wife you out here
okay this girl is just your [ __ ] buddy
but you're me choosing your parents
yeah making her meet all your friends
exactly you don't think that's confusing
at all
weird right yeah
is there stuff that we don't do sexually
that you'd like to try i think i would
like to try bottoming more
um what are you doing tonight she would
like to try bottoming bottoming
was she top before brav
i'm confused maybe he's getting picked
i've never heard a man and a woman say
no
i'd like to be the bottom one
that was
you know what
he's not lying he even asked me
something earlier today and it was wild
but what was that you don't ever eat my
eyes and she was like no i was like i
don't know if i personally want it but i
don't know if i personally not want it
like if it takes a relationship to the
next level then
[ __ ] you want it okay let's be very
clear my son
you're not gonna like fiend for it but
he'd love it if you black yo you [ __ ]
bend over so i can eat that ass
you do it he do it yeah yeah yeah hey
man show me your nether region so i can
go through that and explore star trek
voyager muddy water yeah yeah let me let
me put your waters exactly let's make
some muddy water that is nasty hey man
let me go through your dark puddle okay
later later alligators
let's go to the bayou
that's a good one
that's good
i want my dick sucked more like damn
like i bro like man like i'd be in you
out this isn't this expecting to get my
dick sick like this is dancing damn bro
like whoa
yeah you know there's just certain
things you're gonna have to accept them
like if a girl really don't like eating
or sucking dick you don't want her to
suck your dick you know one or two and
the hugs of that changing with time are
very slim to none
and so even as a force like you could
ask for it and maybe you see a little
uptick but eventually if they're not
into it it's like
and i'm over the mindset that if a
girl's not into it i just don't even
bother so i'm not even mad at people
yeah and it's like there's some people
who suck dick reluctantly there's
nothing less sexy than that oh yeah you
know people try to suck dick with
dignity it's like ruff
listen lose your self-esteem and get in
there slob on the knob exactly you're
not supposed to look pretty you're
supposed to make a mess let's go you're
supposed to look like kids who
discovered crayola okay not supposed to
look pretty spray it all over your face
smack yourself with the go all right put
it in your mouth gobble gobble okay
because some of y'all how you got to be
trying to psych dick with dignity like
adjusting your makeup as you do it no i
want to see that makeup run down your
face
same thing more eating yeah he's
supposed to go in it's like listen save
the feminism for the streets in the
sheets let's do it on the count of three
name who likes who more in this
relationship one two three both means
you
i don't know
why do you think me
i don't know you're really into me i
feel that it's been fun to hang out i'm
really into you too
those eyes
he tried to recover two at the end and
i'm really into you it's been fun and
but the way he started that everyone
understood damn you [ __ ] up you [ __ ]
up yeah yeah i don't know i just like
you're really into me and um it's been
really fun to hang out
oh great one two three yeah
is that true
yeah i feel
that emotionally i have emotional
issues
what are your emotional issues
saying how i feel because
it's always snapped back on me in my
past
what you guessed it you was right what'd
i say
talk about she has some kind of thing
that
it prevents her from putting a label
that's what it is he was right there's
something out there that
prevents her from putting a label you
called it
i said that
but
it was clear sometimes people make up
excuses like this because they're just
not that into the other person that
they're across fair but she anyways
because here's what i'm gathering okay
she acknowledges that he likes her more
okay no that's not what he said no
that's what she just said who likes two
more one two three yeah
is that true
oh okay okay so peep game
game where this is matt matters she she
says she can't yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yes yourself that has nothing to do with
how strongly you feel about the other
person okay so
i thought it was the opposite so even if
she did express herself she doesn't like
him as much as he likes her which again
it's not inherently wrong i'm not mad at
that but you have to understand it's
like it also manifests even in the
sex
where it's like he's willing to give
more than she's willing to reciprocate
you did what i'm saying and then even
him he's like i want to be with you i
don't want to be with you okay you like
me more so there's like yeah yeah yeah
yeah
clearly he's way more invested in this
[ __ ] in that regard yeah right so
there's an interesting thing there and
look maybe it is something past who
knows maybe something else who knows i'm
not gonna tell you but
oftentimes
people mask a lot of their disinterest
or their lack of interest in a specific
person in past issues when really the
truth is
you're not really that into the other
person at least not as much as to want
to be in a relationship
have you been screwed over in the past
is that why a lot of times so there's a
trusting what would happen if we are
pregnant
you're not keeping the baby
do you guys have kids i got a kid she
told me that she'd never get with
somebody with a kid either
puss pus
you see what i'm saying you're good you
see what i'm saying they're good right
you're good people mask it on a lot of
stuff listen if you're with somebody
listen and i never had this happen
before where the individual across from
you is constantly telling you indirectly
they don't want to be with you but it's
kind of you right they don't say i don't
want to be they'll be like i wouldn't be
with somebody who's been single for more
than five years you were being single
for more than five years or they might
say something like um i don't want to be
with anybody who
doesn't constantly want to travel you're
much more of a homebody you know what
i'm saying like they'll find ways and
they know that you're a homebody and
they'll still say that it's like
just say you don't want to be you know
what it is what you're convenient dude
you're convenient for now yeah but
you're not you're not it you're not
you're not that guy yes you're not that
guy that happens sometimes and it's okay
it is cool but i'm just saying that's
what i see it's one of the reasons why
you don't want to commit to me is
because i have a kid no
i wanna i want to at least start my
career be financially stable before i
bring another life into this world maybe
i missed something he said you don't
want to be with me because my kid no no
i want to be a stable relationship a
stable point in my life before i bring a
kid that's going to do with this
question
non-sequitur no you know that's nonsense
politician [ __ ] yeah but hey why am i
not good enough for you it's just the
stability in general that i want
and that's my answer
i mean like for being stable and stuff
like mind you like you know like i have
done stuff in my life to make my life a
lot tougher for me why continue to mess
with me if you don't see stability
coming or but that's why i'm still here
because i see that you're working on it
also it's not even just you it's me
because i want to be the best i can be
for you what if i think you're already
best for me
but i don't think that but then that's
not what i want what does that what is
that if i think that you're good enough
for me and that's okay then that's
[ __ ] because it's just how i feel
that's such a lame answer
there is something unappealing and
off-putting
when you express that you're not
interested in being someone for whatever
reason and they're like well i don't
want to be with me you should want to be
with me it's [ __ ] [ __ ] it's like
the person doesn't want to be with you
more because you've said that now maybe
you enjoyed it because you got it off
your chest and you said how you express
yourself but in terms of turning the
situation around this is the last way to
do it yeah um take it out yeah man she
knocked that into you bro take it out i
don't know how else to say to you you're
convenient yo yo maybe you'll realize it
sooner or later but yeah
that's why it's fine but it is what it
is yeah that's actually you've been
thinking that hell this whole [ __ ]
video and some people like oh they would
make such a cute couple you know he
really likes her it doesn't matter she's
not feeling she's not feeling the same
way clearly that's not working it's a
one-way street i would never be with a
girl who's under five foot seven girls
like five foot two it's like rough you
wanna tell somebody you're not into them
you found a lot of indirect ways to do
so how do you see this ending
with you leading
really
i'm spilling all my emotions that i've
had like you know trapped up and i'm
trying to give it to you and it's like
damn like i feel like that's not enough
and it sucks sometimes because like i
want it to be enough and i want to be
with you but you just make it tough but
i haven't given up though so you feel me
like you always told me people give up
in your life and
you know i haven't given up
it's being worked on and it's getting
much closer much closer
this is a sponsored piece for acting
that was a very generic answer
but yeah
it's okay hey man
keep fighting brother i guess if you
really want to and i think that was a
cute thing ah man people have given up
on you so i'm not going to give up on
you and i i think that's that kind of
like movie thing where the guy keeps
chasing the woman keeps chasing and
eventually she turns it around but what
they don't show you often in real life
and what actually happens is that the
more you go after the more aggressive
and to keep more you keep pushing the
more repulsed the person comes by you
it's like and they actually go back to
you when you stop chasing
they go to you when you stop chasing
mind you when you chase you chase you
chase you chase did you notice the only
time that she indicated any kind of
serious interest in him when he said i
might sleep with other people she's like
you know what i'd probably feel jealous
that's the only time
that's the only time i had any
indication that this girl really wants
that kind of attachment that's the only
time but then again yeah if you stop
chasing brother that's crazy yeah you
know and that's not really like people
are going to take oh that's a mind game
or whatever what not i i believe it's
just how the human body is and sometimes
when you lack interest you're just like
you know what you turn me the [ __ ] off
now and you back off that's where people
usually come back around and be like
yeah but because there's that thing
that's missing people taking you for
granted you know what they say
people are
you often realize what you have when
it's gone so that's pretty much it
that's
when it's gone we start missing you yo
those little things those little things
that were there in your life are not
there the calls the back rub the booty
rubs the feet rubs and all that and the
time you had together you take that [ __ ]
for granted when the [ __ ] fed
up when that moments
when the [ __ ] fed up and leave
and you start realizing that and then
you start coming back on that yeah yeah
it's true she did just really
i'd be jealous girl wow maybe i'm
sensitive to it because i'm used to
seeing the little signs before someone's
like trying to leave or someone's not
interested and i'm okay with that oh i
see what's going on and it's cool yeah
you know i've had people try to gaslight
no no no i'm not losing interest a week
or two later we should stop seeing each
other i knew it was coming you feel what
i'm saying you think it's because you
think it's because you face rejection a
lot so now you know the signs because
you've been watching this like ace of
base yeah are you satisfied me
personally i feel like people are not
that difficult to read
okay
it's been my experience it's very rare
that i'm like what that's how you feel
like i think if women are really
interested in you they have very overt
ways of showing it yeah they're not
interested they also have very different
ways of showing it and sometimes it
happens in the little subtle things
but it's still fairly clear in my
experience it's hard to hide that stuff
at least for me
you know so i've always kind of felt it
when there's like a bit of that
imbalance and the other person's not
into me at all or whatever and like when
that happens i'm like cool i could feel
it so
what i would say is don't waste your
time if you're that person in that
situation don't waste your time because
it is oasis you think you're fighting
you're doing something noble you're
gonna be the one that sweeps them off
the feet but the truth is they're never
gonna look at you like that dude because
you're so desperate for them
and for most people that's just not hot
that's not hot you're not that guy they
don't try to meet you halfway when you
spill your guts to them if they don't
only like reciprocate at all like bruh
and he feels it he knows she's not
reciprocating he knows
he's getting more frustrated yeah so
yeah
at some point you know whatever i get it
guys take on labels okay i understand
what it is that you're doing people want
to do all the things that girl boyfriend
girlfriends do but then they don't want
to be boyfriend i was like just do it be
in that committed relationship you guys
are already doing it we're not sleeping
with anybody else we're going out on
dates we're spending time together we're
getting to know each other but we're not
it's like
okay hey man y'all do whatever y'all
want to do but i think this avoiding of
labels is i think people trying to keep
one foot out the door so that they have
plausible deniability be like well
listen if i don't leave it's fine
because we didn't really commit
you know what i'm saying it's like
they're ready to quit at any point
that's what it feels like and it was
from my perspective so
maybe you disagree what do you think no
i agree yeah
that makes sense yeah what do you guys
think do you guys agree with our stance
or disagree maybe you don't like our
stance on labels